uh suicide squad yeah uh the detachable
kid tdk tdk uh james gunn recently said
uh maybe i'm misquoting but something
like uh hey he didn't die
is that true that's true uh critical
critical condition was my the last you
hear of my
uh
my character's plight why do you think
he said that
why do you think why do you think he
said that i think it's important to be
accurate when people are making
assumptions about he was ripped apart
what i saw the movie
that was his thing he did to cover this
that was his ability to be detached and
then reattached it comes right back
together i think he might have said that
because he wants to bring you back
somewhere listen no one's arguing with
that
how is it how much do you love working
with james gone
you guys have had a relationship i've
had a relationship a long time but
you've had a relationship probably
longer probably just like maybe eight
months longer maybe eight months yeah i
think we're right about the same time um
but uh i met james auditioning for
slither that's right and as i was
leaving the room i said where are you
guys going to film this and he said
vancouver i said oh i'm canadian
he said is that right
he wrote it down
here and i think he did i think that's
how i got the role because you know
hiring local cheaper it's a big deal
you'll live in vancouver while we're
shooting this we'll pay you a lot less
we'll pay you in canadian
it's not about how much you get paid i
think it's about their the tax credit
stuff oh tax credit stuff yeah but you
guys had a great working relationship oh
my god he
[Music]
when is the last time you watched an
episode of smallville tom
i mean i i don't even probably forever
what do you say we revisit well
like watch an entire episode
no i mean like watch an entire series
join tom welling and michael rosenbaum
every week as they rewind every episode
of smallville and discuss their
experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast first of all he loves
his job he and he's really really good
at he really enjoys
telling stories and just dreaming up
these crazy kooky things and then making
them happen sure and he sees it all
unfolding in front of him after all this
you know build up and creating and
putting it all together and then finally
the pieces come together and he's so
jazzed about it
and when this broke down and this won't
work and this guy can't do it and now
this isn't working right and it all
falls apart he doesn't
fall apart he just kind of laughs oh
jesus okay all right look here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna uh okay okay
you've seen him that happened where it's
like holy [ __ ] the days could be ruined
everything could be thrown away
and he steps up when he it's it's
watching someone uh you know do a job
that's easy is is great and watching how
much fun they have that's fantastic
watching someone deal with adversity i
think you see far more of their
character and integrity
and that's where i think uh one of the
many places
james excels that makes me think right
when you said that it makes me think
about myself
how i deal with adversity
um
i'm
i'm pretty good but do you lose your
temper
um
no
i sort of like there you know there was
there was one instance on on a set on
set that uh
we had to block shoot because it was
raining and we couldn't do things on
sticks and we had to so we had to shoot
in one direction for 10 pages
everything in that direction and then
turn around
and i was completely lost completely
lost like i i couldn't i mean
it was hard for me to understand what
was happening
it was just very
and my that's what first ads are for
that's what your dp is for if you have
good ones and um
i remember going hey
um
bradley and
my first ad i said hey come here for a
second let's let's have a conversation
and i just looked at him and i go
i don't know what the [ __ ] to do
they go all right all right well it's
this is difficult you know they said it
was you know this is hard let's let's
figure out yeah because my mind doesn't
work like this i'm more linear this is
this is hard to fathom to shoot
everything in this direction and
remember exactly he's like all right
well let us help you and that was a very
s
i felt like that was a good decision as
opposed to just going all right here's
what we're going to do and because i
think i would have failed i needed help
at this moment it only happened one day
but i felt
it did make me feel like a failure even
though
i know i was so hard on myself it sounds
like you did everything right i know but
i remember i was like you can't do this
by yourself you're a grown [ __ ] man
you can't [ __ ] handle this that's the
your child talks like that no no no i
don't have a child but it's like the the
interlude i mean you're the energy dude
the inner child you can't that's how he
talks to you he's something send that
kid to his room yeah you go to your
[ __ ] room kid
you